If you support socialism,
people will always ask you to name a country where socialism works,
and it's like, which one?
It worked pretty much everywhere.
Not Cambodia and some parts of Eastern Europe
because they weren't really social.
But the point is that it was working for poor people
and colonized people.
That's why the United States
through everything it had at socialism during the Cold War,
to try to keep it from continuing to work.
If socialism doesn't work,
then why does the United States have to keep fighting it all the time?
It works at taking their colonial property back
and actually giving it to the people who work and live there.
That's the whole point.
That's the big
evil socialism that the government has been trying to scare you with
since they put it in your curriculums in school.
Every country where socialism was attempted started dirt poor,
war torn, or colonized.
And then these people,
these Westerners,
tell you to compare them to the rich, colonizer,
war mongering countries.
It's ridiculous.
And you're being gaslit if you think it's fair to compare a poor
postwar socialist country
that
probably just got rid of feudalism and started trying to do socialism
with anyone in Europe or the United States.
What you need to be doing
in order to achieve some clarity for this capitalism
socialism comparison
is comparing the poor socialist countries with the poor
capitalist countries.
Countries who started poor a certain point in time.
And watch their Development.
Go ahead. Look at subs of hair in Africa.
How's capitalism doing there?
Look at Latin America
with all of their interventions from the US
to make sure that capitalism would be going strong.
And they get so worked up
talking about the refugees from communist countries
where they were fleeing real poverty.
Yeah, poverty created by US sanctions.
But they never mentioned that
the majority of economic refugees come from poor
capitalist countries.
Why isn't capitalism working in those poor places?
That's because capitalism only works for rich people.